>>> A STRAIGHTRWARD AND NO
COMPLIMENTARY AMERICAN
ASSESSMENT TODAY OF RUSSIAN
TROOP MORALE.
THIS IS GENERAL FRANK McKENZIE.
HE SAYS MOSCOW'S MILITARY IS
FLAILING.
>> YOU CAN EQUIP AN ARMY.
YOU CAN'T GIVE AN ARMY THE
FIGHTING SPIRIT OF THE
INDIVIDUAL SOLDIER.
THEY DON'T APPEAR TO BE
PARTICULARLY MOTIVATED OR
PARTICULARLY ENGAGED IN THE
CAMPAIGN THAT THEY'RE
UNDERTAKING.
>> STILL TODAY RUSSIAN BOMBS ARE
PUSHING CLOSER AND CLOSER TO
NATO TERRITORY.
RUSSIA LAUNCHING SIX MISSILES AT
LVIV EARLIER TODAY.
THE CITY ONLY 43 MILES FROM THE
POLISH BORDER.
LET'S BRING IN OUR MILITARY
ANALYST, RETIRED LIEUTENANT
GENERAL HERTLING.
WHEN YOU HEAR GENERAL McKENZIE
HERE, THAT'S A POINT YOU'VE
MADE, THAT THE RUSSIAN ARMY IS
DEMONSTRATING INCOMPETENCE AND
WITH THAT COMES MORALE PROBLEMS.
AND SO YOU HAVE THAT ON THE
TABLE, BUT YET, I ALSO JUST WANT
TO BRING UP THIS CLOSE-UP OF
WHERE WE'VE SEEN PROGRESS AROUND
KYIV, THE RUSSIANS WANTED TO
TAKE KYIV IN DAYS.
WE'RE IN WEEK FOUR.
THEY'VE FAILED MISERABLY AT THAT
TASK AND YET THEY ARE CLOSER AND
HAVE A BIT OF A CIRCLE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE PLACES STRUCK IN
RECENT DAYS.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> TELLS ME THEY CAN'T SUSTAIN
THAT FIGHT, JOHN.
AGAIN, AS WE'VE TALKED MULTIPLE
TIMES BEFORE, THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE LOGISTIC SUPPORT AND THEY'RE
LOSING COMBAT POWER ON A DAILY
BASIS.
ONE OF THE THINGS GENERAL
McKENZIE MENTIONED, HE FAILED TO
MENTION THE LACK OF LEADERSHIP
IN THE RUSSIAN ARMY.
THEY'VE NOT PLANNED THIS FIGHT
WELL.
THEY HAVE OVEREXTENDED
THEMSELVES.
AND NOT ONLY DO THEY NOT HAVE
THE WILL WITHIN THE FORCE, THEY
HAVE NOT LED THE FORCE WELL.
SO AS THEY ATTEMPT TO GET CLOSER
AND CLOSER TO KYIV, REMEMBER,
THEIR MAIN MISSION IN MAKING
THAT AS THEIR PRIMARY OBJECTIVE
WAS TO TAKE OVER THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT.
THE FIGHT THEY'RE APPROACHING IN
UKRAINE -- EXCUSE ME, IN KYIV IS
GOING TO BE ONE OF ARTILLERY
BATTLES, ARTILLY DUELS AND
CONTINUOUS TERROR.
THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE AN
INDICATOR THAT THEY HAVE THE
FORCE TO ACTUALLY OVERCOME THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT IN THE
CAPITAL CITY.
>> AND BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN SUCH
A SLOG FOR THE RUSSIANS ON THE
GROUND, ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
WATCH IS WHAT ARE THEY TRYING TO
DO FROM THE AIR.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE SEEN,
RELATIVELY QUIET IN THE WESTERN
PART OF THE COUNTRY BUT IN
RECENT DAYS AND HOURS, MORE
RUSSIAN STRIKES OUT HERE IN THE
WEST.
YOU SEE LVIV HERE AND THE
STRIKES AROUND IT.
THERE ARE AIR BASES THERE,
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS,
INCLUDING THIS AIRCRAFT REPAIR
FACTORY TODAY WHERE THERE'S BEEN
A BIG DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER WE
SHOULD SEND MORE MiGS INTO
UKRAINE.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
THE RUSSIAN TARGETING?
>> WELL, IT TELLS ME SOMETHING.
FIRST OF ALL, ABOUT THEIR
CAMPAIGN PLAN.
THEY ARE SHIFTING.
WHAT THE RUSSIANS WANTED TO DO
IS WHAT'S CALLED A BATTLE OF
ANNIHILATION.
THEY WANTED TO TAKE THE CAPITAL
AND THEY WANTED TO SURROUND ALL
THE FORCES AND DEFEAT THEM BY
JUST SURROUNDING THEM FROM THE
NORTH AND THE SOUTH.
THEY HAVE NOT DONE THAT.
NOW THEY ARE TRANSITIONING, I
BELIEVE, TO A BATTLE OF
ATTRITION, WHICH MEANS THEY'RE
TRYING TO PICK OFF TARGETS,
TRYING TO DO THINGS.
I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF DESPERATION IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN WESTERN
UKRAINE BECAUSE THEY ARE
SHOOTING MISSILES, DROPPING
BOMBS, HOPEFULLY TRYING TO TAKE
OUT THE LOGISTICS FROM THE
UKRAINIAN FORCE.
NOT ONLY WHAT THEY HAVE IN
COUNTRY, BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY
THE TRANSFER OF ARMS FROM NATO
COUNTRIES.
SO THEY ARE DESPERATELY TRYING
TO STRUGGLE TO AFFECT THE
UKRAINIAN LOGISTICS AND SUPPLY
SUPPORT BECAUSE IN A BATTLE OF
ATTRITION, LODGEIGISTICS BECOME
CRITICAL AND IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT TO THE UKRAINIANS
MAINTAINING THEIR ACTIVE
DEFENSE.
>> THE RESUPPLY IS AN ISSUE
YOU'VE BROUGHT UP REPEATEDLY AS
WELL.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE
LISTENING WHEN IVAN WATSON WAS
REPORTING.
HE INTERVIEWED A UKRAINIAN
COMMANDER WHO SAYS HE IS
BEGINNING TO GET MORE WEAPONS
SENT IN.
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
REPEATEDLY.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO DO MORE.
POLITICAL PRESSURE FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO DO MORE.
POLITICAL PRESSURE IN NATO
COUNTRIES DO MORE.
YOU'VE MADE THE POINT THAT WE
ARE NOT SEEING SOME OF THIS
BECAUSE IT'S CLASSIFIED AND IT'S
A MILITARY OPERATION.
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT, A UKRAINIAN
COMMANDER IN THE FIELD SAYING
HE'S BEGINNING TO GET MORE
SHOULDER-FIRED MISSILES, WHAT
DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD
MAKE THE POINT THAT IVAN'S
INTERVIEW WAS WITH A TERRITORIAL
COMMANDER, TOO.
SO THAT'S THEIR -- THE
EQUIVALENT OF THEIR NATIONAL
GUARD.
THE MILITIA THEY'VE CALLED UP.
THE ACTIVE UKRAINIAN ARMY HAS
BEEN GETTING SOME REALLY GOOD
EQUIPMENT FOR A WHILE.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
TERRITORIALS, THE FOLKS STANDING
UP TO DEFEND THEIR HOMELAND, NOW
GETTING SOME OF THOSE SUPPLIES,
IT TELLS ME THE SUPPLIES ARE
GETTING THROUGH.
I WOULD ADD TO THAT, NOT ONLY
ARE THE SUPPLY LINES DELIVERING
THE WEAPONS, THE KINDS OF THINGS
THESE FORCES NEED, BUT IT'S BEEN
INTERESTING TO ME AND FROM MY
SOURCES I'VE HEARD QUITE A BIT
OF UKRAINIAN ARMY AND
TERRITORIAL FORCES TAKING OVER
THE ABANDONED RUSSIAN EQUIPMENT
AND THAT'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT.
NOT JUST TANKS AND PERSONNEL
CARRIERS BUT ARTILLERY PIECES
AND TURNING THEM AROUND ON THE
ENEMY.
ARMIES THROUGHOUT HISTORY HAVE
TRIED TO DO THAT WITH THEIR
ENEMIES.
IT APPEARS UKRAINE IS BEING VERY
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF LEADERSHI